[Music]
yeah oh yeah oh yeah come on play your
game you rogue okay no go here I feel
the power but I know thing
oh oh that's the thing I turned into a
swastika and I turned into rain blood
ray Persky no come on
how is that fair jiggle-jiggle-jiggle
fast booth bro no death
yeah no what happened no huh yes
No
why just play man what does that mean
what do you mean just play did i flick
oh hell me bro how do I help you breathe
bear she's helping you breathe merci
got it helicopter test wait oh oh you ah
you come with me lady make out with me
let me get all of you I hate melons
I hate him to death don't you know this
woman
hey I just wanted to tell you that I
didn't want anything to actually happen
[Music]
I can't believe you got me another ding
damned melon put it in the spot put one
in the slot put me in the slot well I
just tell you though be near incoming
[Applause]
[Music]
all right got that one that was easy
enough one more trap
yeah I got you dead all right moving on
Oh wah steam on story your name is woz
Iman the Gerber that is your wife I
can't read this up good you fat ass no
no stop stop going there avoid the
spikes
I didn't avoid this white boy spike go
as fast as you can until you got all
right taking this a lot Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah got you that time
[Applause]
Paul and swore throw ball and swore
throw ball ants were throw-in words ball
in word through parlance words bill
parlance word throw ball lands were
throw I bet you can't do it the force
field did not help that's good I guess
[Music]
it's all it's all dicks so many dicks
and pasta all my back oh I'm ok now
ok let's carry on this impossible level
wait a minute wait a minute what Humpty
okay so far so oh wow that wasn't
swinging before I am NOT gonna be beaten
by you
ah this is perfectly normal for me ah
God dingus dammit dammit helicopter man
pot booth what the hell is going on with
my neck oh dude me you know it got hard
real quick ha ha ha
oh bloody Bo did something explode
thanks kid oh let's go [ __ ] yeah
might just be the artist boon around
I've ever been on
gotta hit all of this so many pins to
the balls the survivor died really miss
Valerius survived in Spain for me
[Laughter]
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow leave a light add it to your
favorites or share with your friends on
Facebook and Twitter thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
you